As some of you may know, the anti-choice Republicans
in the United States have been pushing all
sorts of bills that would qualify a fetus
as a person and thus it would open up the
door to a lot of what I would consider really
problematic possibilities.
Like for example, prison for mothers who have
abortions, prison for doctors who perform
abortions, murder charges for abortions, manslaughter
charges for miscarriage.
I mean really ugly backwards stuff.
And one of those states is Alabama and it
has just gotten really disturbing.
They're actually related to a story that's
not directly about abortion, but we need to
sort of think critically about what the implications
here are.
Now before I get to the full story, this is
the type of story that I believe is important
to cover, but this story is going to be demonetized
by youtube.
We've been talking about these issues on youtube.
Youtube is an important revenue source for
us, but these are important stories for us
to cover.
So consider supporting us with a membership@davidpacman.com
so that we can just keep covering the stories
that deserve coverage and not have to worry
about how it's going to impact the show's
revenue.
So the story is as follows, a 27 year old
Alabama woman was shot in the stomach while
pregnant and she was shot by another woman
and being shot in the stomach resulted in
a miscarriage.
Um, she is now being charged with manslaughter
for that miscarriage, which of course is connected
to her being the victim of a shooting.
So there's a whole bunch of details here that
can be discussed.
One is that the fight that led to the shooting
was between the pregnant woman Marshae Jones
and another woman who were fighting over the
fetus's father.
Um, the shooter, Ebony Jamison, was charged
with manslaughter initially and not indicted
by a grand jury.
So that charge was dismissed.
Now Jones has been indicted on a manslaughter
charge.
The argument being made by police in pleasant
grove, Alabama is that the mother instigated
the argument with the other woman that the
victim here is the unborn fetus.
And were it not for the instigation of the
mother that none of this would have happened.
Therefore, the mother should be charged with
manslaughter.
Now you might laugh this off and say, Alabama,
this wouldn't happen anywhere else.
That's not true.
There are 38 states that classify fetuses
as victims in homicide or assault.
And the truth is that sometimes that does
make sense.
Okay.
If a burglary gone wrong, leads to a burglar
shooting a pregnant woman and both the woman
and the fetus die.
The fact that there was the potential for
life there and that to actual or potential
lives were cut short should be considered
by the law.
The problem is that in places like Alabama,
it's being applied in really ridiculous ways
that truly stretched credulity and require,
I, I mean I, I'd call it imagination and in
a sense are criminalizing of pregnancy.
And the reason that lots of, uh, anti choice
activists love this indictment is they understand,
they understand the long game and they see
that prosecution for an abortion is only half
a step beyond what we're seeing in Alabama
right now.
So understand that in reading the details
of the situation, it may well be that the
mother instigated or escalated or perpetuated
this disagreement with the other woman, but
escalating the fight or the argument doesn't
excuse the person with the gun who decided
to do the shooting, which led to the death
of the fetus.
And it will be used by the anti choice, right,
to push for changes.
Uh, oh, that would open the door to and encourage
criminal charges for women having abortions.
So there's a lot of disagreement on this one,
even including within some enclaves of the
left.
So I want to hear from you about it.
What do you think about this research, the
details of the story first, uh, and then let
me know
what
you think.